Moeller is out of control he's biased he
shooted from the hip
he used to be this cool prosecutor who
wasn't going to prosecute anybody but
now all of a sudden after some
investigation or whatever he's starting
to prosecute people and it gets worse we
may now have proof the investigation was
weaponized to destroy his presidency for
partisan political purposes and to
disenfranchise millions of American
voters now if that's true we have a coup
on our hands in America who a coup
Muller has been hiding these intentions
just like the way the word coup has
spent centuries hiding the letter P but
waters waters has stumbled onto
something here the phrase if that's true
it's a brilliant journalistic tool known
as guessing a guess is just a fact that
hasn't been born yet you see you can't
wait for the news to be true before you
report it that's how you get caught off
guard sometimes you have to tell the
people what the truth might be so they
can get ahead of being afraid of it
watch I'll do it for you right now
Muller is assembling a team of
anti-trump FBI agents to take down the
President and if that's true he's part
of a deep state conspiracy to end up
American democracy and install a king
and if that's true that King would
probably be a liberal Frankenstein
monster built at Obama's secret cloning
lab and if that's true
Her Royal Highness Susan B shabbos
Kennedy Roosevelt will take our guns and
abort us all Wow oh did you see how
easily I just scared myself into the
truth now I know what you're thinking
the sex in Basic Instinct was real right
but also I know what else you're
thinking how can we stop Muller after
doing no research I came to the
conclusion that the only person who can
take down a special prosecutor is an
even more special prosecutor and I know
the perfect man for the job me
hi Jordan Klepper by the power vested in
me by being on television appoint myself
to the position of special prosecutor
first question who is Robert Muller now
we know that he has worked in San
Francisco Boston and Washington DC one
of those cities have in common
unsolved murders now I'm not saying
Muller is responsible for all of them
but statistically it's impossible to
disprove second question is this guy
even American he claims to have been
born right here in New York City at a
place called doctors Hospital which
sounds like a three year old just made
it up so I sent Erin and Josh out to
this so-called hospital to follow this
lead guys what you got Jordan we have
talked to at least three or four people
outside of the hospital today and none
of them even remember Bob Muller being
born here 74 years ago
yeah it's technically not even a
hospital anymore so bye-bye Bertha this
guy's it is so obvious blow this thing
up the investigation we oh yeah oh my
god no no no got it yes Wow our first
lead and I gotta tell you that's a home
run
molars New York birth is a total
fabrication and if he hasn't won if he
wasn't born here then who knows where he
was born
Kenya Pakistan the upside down I'm gonna
be special or prosecuting until this
Moeller investigation is exterminated
and like all great leaders I'm enlisting
the help of the best people you there's
a call to action freethinkers bring me
the dirt on robert muller tweet it to us
with the hashtag Muller dirt nothing is
too outlandish Muller is a Russian
operative bring it Muller is Hillary
Clinton in a mask on stilts yeah I'm
listening Muller is a liberal chimera
with the head of a falcon on the body of
a 70s era filing cabinet yeah okay
sounds reasonable and if that's true who
knows how many slimy dossiers he could
be storing in his chest cavity that's
scary stuff and I can't wait for it to
be true
[Music]